but even for yourself as a content
creator do you miss him as a kind like
would you selfishly forget about
political of course you don't want him
you would have probably had Bernie over
Biden I would assume maybe somebody else
who would have been your guy if you had
your choice yeah I mean I I think Bernie
is the closest when you look at policy
to me but I've been very critical of the
way Bernie runs his campaign I Bernie
talks about he's a socialist I don't
know I'm not a socialist and I don't
actually think Bernie ran on a socialist
platform but we can get to that
interesting but I I've said to my
audience Trump was great for shows like
mine there's no question about it right
like speaking if I was if I was Voting
not for what I think is best for the
country but what's best for me
financially of course Trump was a gold
mine there's no question about it
[Music]
[Applause]